It's peak pollination season, and my business is scaling fast. To keep the nectar flowing, I need a phone plan with top priority data speeds. That's why I chose Google Fi Wireless. My connections stay strong even when the hive is buzzing. Plus, unlimited plans started $35 a month. Now that's a deal that doesn't stay. Explore Google Fi Wireless plans today. Plus taxes and government fees.
现在是授粉高峰期，我的业务规模正在迅速扩大。为了保持花蜜源源不断，我需要一个拥有最高优先级数据速度的手机套餐。这就是我选择 Google Fi Wireless 的原因。即使蜂巢喧闹，我的连接依然保持强劲。此外，无限流量套餐起步价仅为每月 35 美元。这真是一个不会长久的优惠。立即探索 Google Fi Wireless 套餐。另需税费和政府规费。
Google Fi Wireless is not subject to data traffic deprioritization during times of high network usage. Between email, Zoom, text messages, Slack, and just walking down the hall, workplaces these days offer people more ways than ever to communicate with colleagues. But with these new choices come confusion, you've probably wondered yourself, does my boss need to know about this problem right away? Is it worth bothering her with a text message or can it wait until she checks her email? Does this smiley face emoji make my email look more friendly or less professional? Or both? How can I get to know the new hire in my office when he lives two time zones away? And of course, the classic question, could that meeting have been an email?
Google Fi Wireless 在网络使用高峰期不受数据流量降速影响。从电子邮件、Zoom、短信、Slack 到只是走廊里的偶遇，如今的工作场所为人们提供了比以往更多与同事沟通的方式。但伴随这些新选择而来的却是困惑，你可能也自己琢磨过：我的老板需要马上知道这个问题吗？值得为发短信去打扰她，还是等她查看邮件再说？这个笑脸表情符号会让我的电子邮件看起来更友好还是更不专业？或者两者皆有？当我办公室的新同事住在两个时区之外时，我该如何了解他？当然，还有那个经典问题：那个会议本可以只发一封电子邮件吗？
As workers try to decipher new workplace norms and rules, behavioral scientists are studying virtual communication as well. Their work is offering insight into questions such as how can you decide what's the right mode of communication for a particular work conversation? How can you craft emails that are both authentic and professional? what's the best way to keep your remote boss updated on your work, and what's the best way to develop authentic, strong work relationships with virtual colleagues and with those you see in person. Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association
当员工们试图解读新的职场规范和规则时，行为科学家们也在研究虚拟沟通。他们的工作为以下问题提供了见解：如何为特定的工作对话选择正确的沟通方式？如何撰写既真诚又专业的电子邮件？如何向远程老板汇报工作的最新进展，以及如何与虚拟同事以及面对面见到的同事建立真诚、牢固的工作关系？欢迎收听《心理学说话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学协会的旗舰播客，
that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Andrew Brodsky. Dr. Brodsky is a professor of management at the McCombes School, of Business at the University of Texas at Austin, where he studies workplace communication challenges and the impact of technology on people at work. He has conducted research, led trainings, and consulted with organizations around the world, such as PricewaterhouseCoopers, Amazon, and Dell Technologies. His research has been covered in media outlets, including The Economist, the New York Times,
旨在探讨心理学科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我今天的嘉宾是安德鲁·布罗德斯基博士。布罗德斯基博士是德克萨斯大学奥斯汀分校麦库姆斯商学院的管理学教授，他在那里研究职场沟通挑战以及技术对职场中人的影响。他曾为普华永道、亚马逊和戴尔科技等全球各地的组织进行过研究、领导培训并提供咨询。他的研究已被《经济学人》、《纽约时报》等媒体报道，
Harvard Business Review, and NPR. And he's the author of a new book published in February called Ping, The Secrets of Successful Virtual Communications. Dr. Brodsky, thank you for joining me today. Thank you for having me on the show. We're having this conversation at a time when there's a lot of discussion and turmoil around remote work and return to office directives. Are the issues that you write about in this book mostly of concern to people who work from home, or is this something that affects most workers, even those who work in person?
《哈佛商业评论》和 NPR。他是 2 月份出版的新书《拼：成功虚拟沟通的秘密》（Ping, The Secrets of Successful Virtual Communications）的作者。布罗德斯基博士，感谢您今天做客节目。谢谢邀请我参加节目。我们进行这场对话的背景是，关于远程办公和重返办公室指令存在着大量的讨论和混乱。你在书中写到的问题主要是远程办公人员所关心的，还是说这会影响到大多数员工，甚至是那些现场办公的员工？
Part of the reason I wrote this book is I saw so many conversations happening in the media between executives, is remote work good, is it bad? And the thing they're all missing is that regardless of whether you work from the office, from home, anywhere in between, we are now all virtual communicators. The old way of interacting the office was whenever you had a question, you'd go over to your coworker's cubicle or your knock on their office door, and you'd ask them. Now instead, people send instant messages or Slack messages, even when they're only a couple feet away from someone else.
我写这本书的部分原因是我看到媒体上高管之间有那么多讨论：远程办公是好是坏？但他们都忽略的一点是，无论你是在办公室、在家还是在介于两者之间的任何地方工作，我们现在全都是虚拟沟通者。办公室里旧的互动方式是，每当你遇到问题，你就会走到同事的工位旁或敲响他们办公室的门，然后向他们请教。而现在，人们会发送即时消息或 Slack 消息，哪怕他们离另一个人只有几英尺远。
And it's not all bad because now instead of always interrupting others every time we had a question, people can now respond at their eats. So the key takeaway here is it's not so important about where you work, but the idea that we're all using this technology and understanding how we can use it better is something that can improve outcomes for everyone. With all these modes of communication that are now available, how can people decide what's the right method,
这也不完全是坏事，因为现在大家不用在每次遇到问题时总是打断别人，而是可以按照自己的节奏进行回复。所以这里的关键启示是，重要的不是你在哪里工作，而是我们都在使用这项技术这个事实；理解如何更好地使用它，可以为每个人带来更好的结果。既然现在有这么多沟通方式，人们该如何决定正确的方法呢？
for the right time. How do you know whether a particular question would be best addressed by email or Slack or Zoom or by calling an in-person meeting? So in thinking about this, there's a few key pieces that I talk about in the book. This is one of the core ideas in the book, along with, okay, once we've chosen the mode, how can we best leverage it? But to answer this question, I offer framework in the book. So the framework is the ping framework, so it's easy to remember because it's the book title, with P as perspective taking, I's initiative, N as nonverbal, and G as goals. So with P perspective taking,
在正确的时机。你怎么知道某个特定的问题最好通过电子邮件、Slack、Zoom 还是通过召开线下会议来解决？所以在思考这个问题时，我在书中谈到了几个关键部分。这是书中的核心理念之一，此外还有：一旦我们选择了某种沟通方式，如何才能最好地利用它？为了回答这个问题，我在书中提供了一个框架。这个框架就是 ping 框架，因为书名很容易记住，其中 P 代表视角采择（perspective taking），I 代表主动性（initiative），N 代表非语言（nonverbal），G 代表目标（goals）。对于 P 即视角采择，
you want to think about when you're interacting virtually, we often become much more self-focused because we're just looking at the text of an email. Or even on video, we're looking at a small square of someone else, as opposed to them being right in front of us. So it's important to take a moment to take the perspective of the other person, what mode might they like, How might they interpret my choice of mode?
你想考虑的是，当你进行虚拟互动时，我们往往会变得更加关注自我，因为我们只是在看电子邮件的文字。甚至在视频中，我们看到的也只是别人的一个小方框，而不是他们就在我们面前。因此，花一点时间站在对方的角度思考是很重要的：他们可能喜欢什么方式？他们会如何解读我选择的方式？
How might they interpret my message? And actually going out of your way is even more important virtually. I is initiative. So the idea behind initiative is that you want to think about what is missing from any given mode or interaction and how can we add it back in. So for instance, small talk is often missing virtually because it just feels weird to do that in email.
他们会如何解读我的信息？在虚拟环境中，刻意这样做甚至更加重要。I 代表主动性。主动性的背后的理念是，你需要思考任何给定的沟通方式或互动中缺少了什么，以及我们该如何将其补回来。例如，虚拟互动中往往缺少闲聊，因为在电子邮件中这样做会让人感觉很奇怪。
And so thinking about how can I add back in that human element can be incredibly important. And for nonverbal, it's understanding what nonverbal behavior exists within different modes of interaction. And there's a whole lot of different ones that happen virtually. So for video, should you be staring at the other person, staring at your webcam, in email and instant message, typos can relay emotion, time of day can relay power in terms of when you sent the message. There are so many different ones that understanding what exists in each one and how to leverage them can be really been. efficient. And then lastly, arguably the most important to mention, G, goals. And this gets into the point about what mode will be best depends on your goal. So a common topic is cameras on or
因此，思考如何将这种人性化元素加回来会极其重要。至于非语言，则是要理解不同的互动方式中存在着哪些非语言行为。虚拟环境中会发生各种各样不同的非语言行为。比如在视频中，你应该盯着对方看，还是盯着网络摄像头看？在电子邮件和即时消息中，错别字可以传达情绪，发送消息的时间可以传达权力关系。有太多不同的行为了，理解每种行为的存在方式以及如何利用它们会非常高效。最后，可以说是最重要的一点，G 代表目标。这就切入了这样一个观点：哪种沟通方式最好取决于你的目标。因此，一个常见的话题是开会时要不要开摄像头。
cameras off meetings. What's better? What's worse? And it depends on your goal. So if you're trying to show you're engaged or if it's a new relationship and you want to build trust, having that camera on can be really handy. But if it's an existing team, you already know each other well, cameras often have been shown to be useful because it gets rid of that Zoom fatigue or video conferencing fatigue that causes that extra stress on all of us. So it really depends on your goal what's going to be best. So that PING framework is what I use to tie together all the different recommendations of the book so that they'll hopefully be more memorable and actionable for anyone who reads it. are there some kinds of communications or conversations that absolutely have to be done in person
开摄像头好还是不好？哪个更好？哪个更糟？这取决于你的目标。因此，如果你是想表现出你的投入，或者如果这是一段新关系并且你想建立信任，开着摄像头会非常有用。但如果是一个现有的团队，你们已经彼此非常熟悉，事实证明不开摄像头通常也很有用，因为这消除了那种给我们所有人带来额外压力的“Zoom 疲劳”或视频会议疲劳。所以，什么方式最好真的取决于你的目标。因此，我用这个 PING 框架将书中的所有不同建议串联起来，希望对于任何阅读它的人来说，这些建议都更具记忆性和可操作性。有没有哪种沟通或对话是绝对必须面对面进行的？
or can pretty much anything be done effectively remotely? I have a two-part answer for that one. The first is, yes, certain things are just better in person. It just not as fun to share a meal with someone when they're on the screen. You can't really taste their food. It just doesn't have the same effect. That said, people heavily overestimate the importance of impression. person interactions for a whole variety of things. For everyone who's had hours and hours of wasted
还是说几乎任何事情都可以通过远程有效地完成？对于这个问题，我的回答分为两部分。首先，是的，某些事情确实面对面进行更好。当某人出现在屏幕上时，和他们一起用餐就没那么有趣了。你无法真正品尝他们的食物。它就是没有那种效果。话虽如此，人们极大地高估了面对面互动对于各种事情的重要性。对于每个在工作中每周经历无数次浪费时间的会议、而这些会议本该只发一封电子邮件的人来说，
meetings at work every week that should have just been email, you know what I'm talking about, where there's just this need, what I often call the in-person default, where we just compare everything to in-person and we think it's better. And in many cases, that's actually the wrong choice and other modes are a lot more effective. Is the telephone as a mechanism of verbal communication dead. The telephone's an interesting one because it falls in this middle zone where it feels like no one wants to use it anymore, although people are using voice notes even more, which is kind of like telephone, although it's more asynchronous or not real time. It's really a cooler way to talk about voicemail, but it's effectively the same thing. But research shows there's a lot of useful
你们都知道我在说什么，这种需求——我经常称之为“面对面默认值”——让我们把所有事情都与面对面进行比较，并且认为它更好。但在许多情况下，这实际上是错误的抉择，其他方式要有效得多。作为言语沟通机制的电话已经消亡了吗？电话是一个有趣的例子，因为它处于这个中间地带：似乎没有人再想用它了，尽管人们现在甚至更多地使用语音便签，这有点像电话，尽管它更具异步性，或者说不是实时的。这其实是谈论语音信箱的一种更酷的方式，但实际上是一样的。不过研究表明，电话有很多用处，
cases for telephone, or what I like to categorize more broadly as audio only, calls. So that's video calls with your cameras off, is effectively just telephone. And for instance, those calls can help you, compared to video, can cause less fatigue and less stress, because you're not staring at yourself the whole time, worried about your nonverbal behavior, which can really cause negative emotions. So turning the camera off, choosing phone instead of video can be really useful for achieving greater focus. And on the other side, there's a lot of times when your emailing and you're going back and forth and it's taking you like a week to resolve something that would be a lot quicker if you just hopped on a five-minute phone call. So if you said,
或者我更愿意将其广泛分类为纯音频通话。也就是说，关掉摄像头的视频通话实际上就是电话。例如，与视频相比，这些通话可以帮你减少疲劳和压力，因为你不用一直盯着自己看，担心自己的非语言行为，这确实会导致负面情绪。因此，关掉摄像头，选择电话而不是视频，对于实现更高的专注度非常有用。另一方面，很多时候当你发电子邮件时，来来回回花了一个星期才解决的问题，如果直接打个五分钟的电话就能快得多。所以如果你说：
hey, can we just switch this to phone for a quick minute to resolve this? You could save 20 back and forth email sometimes. So one of the things I'm seeing in my research as well as that for many others is that phone or audio can be a really beneficial mode, yet it's often underutilized. What about crucial conversations like hiring and firing? Is there a better way to do that in the current situation we're living in? So when it comes to these crucial conversations, hiring, firing, generally what I recommend is richer is generally better. And what I mean by richer is the more similar it is to face-to-face.
嘿，我们能不能为了快速解决这个问题把通话换成电话聊一分钟？有时你可以省去 20 封来来回回的电子邮件。因此，我在自己的研究以及许多其他人的研究中看到的一点是，电话或音频可以成为一种非常有利的沟通方式，然而它却常常未被充分利用。像招聘和解雇这样至关重要的对话呢？在我们目前所处的环境中，有没有更好的方式来处理这些事情？因此，当涉及到这些至关重要的对话（如招聘、解雇）时，我通常的建议是信息越丰富通常越好。我所说的“信息丰富”是指它越接近面对面交流。
So for hiring, being able to show your enthusiastic excitement is better over a very much. video. Assuming you're actually excited. If you're not actually excited, that it's better to turn your camera off so they can't see it as much and it's better to have a phone call then. So that can be really beneficial to do more richly. The other side of that is it's important to take the perspective of the other person because what you think is best may not be best for them. There was a story going around that went viral of some layoffs that happened in the last couple years where a manager actually insisted that the person being laid off keep their camera on even though they didn't want to. And it makes sense to us, but on the other side, here's a manager who thinks this is the best choice.
对于招聘来说，能够通过视频充分展现出你的热情要好得多。假设你真的很兴奋。如果你其实并不兴奋，最好关掉摄像头，这样他们就看不到那么多了，这时进行电话沟通会更好。因此，采用更丰富的方式会非常有利。另一方面，站在对方的角度思考也很重要，因为你认为最好的方式可能对他们来说并不是最好的。过去几年里流传着这样一个关于裁员的病毒式故事：一位经理实际上坚持被裁的员工保持摄像头开启，即使员工并不想这样。这在我们看来似乎合情合理，但在另一端，这位经理认为这是最佳选择。
I want to be able to see them to express this. But on the other side, the recipients like, I don't want to see my manager to see me crying. I don't want them to see me this. So taking into the other person's perspective as a means of understanding, well, what might be best for them as opposed to what I think is best can be one of the most effective things
我想看着他们来表达这一点。但在另一端，接受裁员的人却觉得：我不想让经理看到我哭泣。我不想让他们看到我这样。因此，设身处地站在对方的角度去理解“对他们来说什么才是最好的，而不是我认为什么最好”，这可能是你在这些情况下可以采取的最有效的措施之一。
you can do in those situations. A major talking point for people who advocate bringing workers back into physical offices has been that in-person work promotes connections among co-workers and makes for better working relationships. Have you found that there is some truth to that
主张将员工带回实体办公室的人的一个主要论点一直是，面对面工作可以促进同事之间的联系，并建立更好的工作关系。你是否发现其中确实有道理？
or can you build relationships that are just as strong? working remotely. The example I like to talk about with executives who view this in-person is the only way you could build culture is actually related to a comedy movie from the 90s, the parent trap, where they basically force divorcing parents into a basement together. The kids did this, hoping their parents would get back together. And of course, it's a movie, it worked.
还是说你也可以建立同样牢固的远程工作关系？我喜欢向那些认为面对面是建立企业文化的唯一途径的高管们讲述的例子，其实与 90 年代的一部喜剧电影《天生一对》（The Parent Trap）有关，电影中他们基本上把闹离婚的父母强行关在地下室里。孩子们这么做是希望父母能复合。当然，这是一部电影，它成功了。
but in reality, this doesn't happen in real life. If you know two divorcing people and you squeeze them into a room together, the outcome's not going to be so great. So this is the same logic that executives are applying to the workplace. We're going to put a bunch of people in the room together and then culture should magically appear. Suddenly they're all going to get along great. And the problem with that logic is that in reality,
但在现实中，这在现实生活中是不会发生的。如果你认识两个正在离婚的人，把他们塞进同一个房间里，结果往往不会太好。这就是高管们应用到工作场所的逻辑。我们要把一群人塞进同一个房间里，然后企业文化就会奇迹般地出现。突然之间，他们所有人都能相处得很好。这种逻辑的问题在于，在现实中，
it just doesn't work so well. If you want to improve culture, where people are located is not one of the main driving factors. I can tell you that forcing people to go to a location that they don't want to and them not feeling like they don't have a voice is one of the worst things you could do
它根本没那么管用。如果你想改善企业文化，员工的所在地并不是主要的驱动因素之一。我可以告诉你，强迫员工去一个他们不想去的地方，让他们觉得自己的声音不被倾听，这是你可以对改善企业文化做的最糟糕的事情之一。
for improving culture. So yes, maybe you do get some marginal benefits by having them together, but it doesn't offset the degree to which they feel like they've lost their voice in the organization, that the organization doesn't care about them anymore. So the big question is not so much, can we just bring them in person it's magically fixed?
所以，是的，也许把他们聚在一起确实能带来一些边际好处，但这无法抵消他们觉得自己在组织中失去了话语权、组织不再关心他们的失落感。因此，重大问题与其说“我们能不能把他们请到现场就能奇迹般地解决问题”，
It's, okay, we're virtual or in person. What can we do best to improve that culture? What about creativity and innovation? Are people naturally more creative when they can bounce ideas around with their coworkers in person? I mean, how can remote workplaces promote the same level of innovation and creativity. It can feel really engaging when you've got a bunch of people in a conference room
不如说是“好吧，我们现在是远程还是面对面。为了改善这种企业文化，我们能做些什么最好？”创造力和创新呢？当员工可以面对面地与同事碰撞想法时，他们是否天生更具创造力？我的意思是，远程工作场所该如何促进同等水平的创新和创造力？当你把一群人聚在会议室里，
and you've got a whiteboard and you're jotting down ideas. And it just can feel really energizing. But the research on brainstorming actually shows that that is not the optimal approach to brainstorming. So the best brainstorming, and now I'm going to talk about the first stages of brainstorming, which is solely idea generation, that has been shown to be better done electronically and separately for a few reasons. The first is, and it's a pretty simple one,
面前摆着白板，随手记下想法时，这会让人感觉非常有参与感。这确实能让人充满活力。但关于头脑风暴的研究实际表明，那并不是头脑风暴的最佳方法。因此，最好的头脑风暴——现在我将讨论头脑风暴的早期阶段，也就是纯粹的想法生成阶段——已被证明通过电子方式和单独进行会更好，原因有几个。首先，这是一个相当简单的原因：
when you have a bunch of people in a room, only one person can talk at a time. So let's just say you've a group of 10, you'd ideally like each person to come up with 20 ideas. We're now talking about 200 ideas. In person, the amount of time it would take to talk about 200 ideas is very high. If everyone was just typing down 20 ideas,
当一群人聚在一个房间里时，一次只能有一个人说话。比方说，你有一个 10 人的小组，你理想情况下希望每个人都能想出 20 个主意。我们现在讨论的就是 200 个主意。在现场，讨论 200 个主意所需的时间是非常多的。如果每个人只是各自打出 20 个主意，
ideas by themselves, it's a lot more productive. The next problem is that when everyone's staring at you in a room, you're concerned they're going to judge your ideas more negatively. So you're less inclined to come up with more divergent or creative ideas that are outside the norm because you're concerned about that judgment. And so having this kind of ability to be on your own a little bit more, not having to wait for other people to finish can be really beneficial. And lastly, when someone else has an idea in a meeting, our brain attaches to that idea suddenly.
每个人都靠自己，这要高效得多。下一个问题是，当房间里的每个人都盯着你看时，你会担心他们会对你的想法做出更负面的评价。因此，由于担心这种评判，你就不太倾向于提出更多超出常规的发散性或创造性想法。因此，这种能够稍微独处、不用等别人完成的能力会非常有益。最后，当会议中的其他人提出一个想法时，我们的大脑会突然依附于那个想法。
So every idea you're thinking about is related to that previous idea you heard as opposed to being something way different. So you don't have that anchoring effect happening in meetings. That happens in meetings when you do it virtually. So early stages of brainstorming are better done via text-based communication generally. But the latter stages where you're agreeing on an idea. So this is when a group needs to come together to figure out, okay, what idea do we want? How do we tweak it?
所以你脑海中想到的每个想法都与你听到的上一个想法有关，而不是截然不同。因此，你在会议中不会产生那种锚定效应。当你虚拟开会时，会议中就不会发生这种情况。因此，头脑风暴的早期阶段通常最好通过基于文本的沟通来完成。但后期的阶段则是需要就某个想法达成一致。也就是说，当一个团队需要聚在一起弄清楚：好吧，我们想要什么想法？我们该如何调整它？
That requires a lot of back and forth. And that's done better synchronously, whether that's a video meeting or an in-person meeting. Your summer starts now with Memorial Day deals at the Home Depot. It's time to fire up summer cookouts with the next grill for burner gas grill on special bye for only $199 and entertain all season with the Hampton Bay West Grove seven-piece outdoor dining set for only $499. This Memorial Day get low prices guaranteed at the Home Depot. While supplies, price invalid May 14th or May 27th, U.S. only exclusions apply. See Home Depot.com slash price match for details.
这需要大量的来来回回沟通。这通过同步方式完成会更好，无论是视频会议还是线下会议。你的夏天从家得宝（The Home Depot）的阵亡将士纪念日特惠开始。是时候用特价仅需 199 美元的 Nextgrill 四火眼燃气烧烤炉开启夏日烧烤了，还可以用仅需 499 美元的汉普顿湾（Hampton Bay）West Grove 七件套户外餐桌椅尽情招待一整个季节。这个阵亡将士纪念日，请到家得宝享受低价保证。售完即止，价格有效期为 5 月 14 日至 5 月 27 日，仅限美国，不适用条款参见 Homedepot.com/pricematch 了解详情。
You said this place was steps from the water. We just haven't found the steps yet. How much did we save? Enough. Enough to get lost! Or you could book a stay with Hilton. Welcome to your oceanfront room. Just steps from the water.
你以前说过这个地方离水边只有几步之遥。我们只是还没找到那几步在哪。我们省了多少钱？够了。够去迷路的了！或者你可以预订希尔顿的住宿。欢迎来到您的海滨房间。距离水边仅几步之遥。
The Hilton sale is on now. Book on Hilton.com or the Hilton app and save up to 20% to get the stay you expected. When you want savings, not surprises. It matters where you stay. Hilton for this day. Let's talk about Zoom and other video meetings. First, you mentioned Zoom fatigue a moment ago.
希尔顿特惠活动正在进行中。在 Hilton.com 或希尔顿 App 上预订，最高可省 20%，获得您期望的住宿体验。当您想要的是省钱，而不是惊吓。住哪里，真的很重要。希尔顿伴您每一次入住。我们来谈谈 Zoom 和其他视频会议。首先，你刚才提到了 Zoom 疲劳。
Is that a real thing? Our video meetings inherently more exhaustive. than other methods of communication. Yes. So there are a variety of studies on Zoom or video conferencing fatigue, and they consistently show that it is more exhausting to be on camera than not. When we're in person, we're not staring at ourselves, and when our camera's off, we're not staring at ourselves.
这是真的吗？视频会议天生就比其他沟通方式更让人筋疲力尽吗？是的。因此，有各种关于 Zoom 或视频会议疲劳的研究，它们一致表明，开摄像头比不开摄像头更让人精疲力竭。当我们面对面时，我们不会盯着自己看；而当我们关掉摄像头时，我们也不会盯着自己看。
And there's also other research that has highlighted that the amount of time you spend staring at yourself during a meeting is correlated with your negative emotion following the meeting. And that set of studies actually did something really funny. They were curious if giving participants alcohol might help improve this effect. And the key thinking was, well, if we drink, we're more social, so maybe we'll be less focused. In what I see as good news from my offering advice to people who are listening or reading
还有其他研究强调，你在会议期间盯着自己的时间长短，与你在会后的负面情绪呈正联。那一组研究实际上做了一件非常有趣的事。他们好奇给参与者喝点酒是否能有助于改善这种效应。他们的核心想法是：如果我们喝酒了，我们会更具社交性，所以可能我们的专注度会降低。在我看来，对于向听书或读书的人提供建议的我来说，这是一个好消息：
the book, alcohol did not help. Fortunately or unfortunately, depending on how you look, at it. So, you know, I wouldn't recommend having a glass of Charney with your meeting because it doesn't make you feel any better and then you might accidentally say some things you didn't intend in the process. But yes, Zoom fatigue, video conferencing fatigue more broadly, is a real effect. So what's the best way to make a good impression on Zoom? How important is it to turn your camera on? When it comes to making a good impression and the importance of camera on, there's a research theory known as channel expansion theory.
酒精并没有起作用。幸运还是不幸，取决于你如何看待它。所以，你知道的，我不会建议你在开会时喝一杯霞多丽白葡萄酒，因为它不会让你感觉更好，而且在此过程中你可能会不小心说出一些你本无意说的话。但是，是的，Zoom 疲劳，或者更广泛地说视频会议疲劳，是一种真实存在的效应。那么，在 Zoom 上留下好印象的最佳方式是什么？开启摄像头有多重要？当谈到留下好印象以及开启摄像头的重要性时，有一个被称为“通道扩展理论”的研究理论。
And the idea behind channel expansion theory is that when you are talking to a stranger, mode matters a lot more than it does when you're talking to someone you're very familiar with or topics you're really familiar about. So in plain language, if I get a text message or an email from a complete stranger or someone who's barely in acquaintance, there's a strong likelihood I'm going to misinterpret their message because I don't understand how they normally communicate. But if I get a text message or email from my partner or my best friend, I know exactly what they're saying. I know how to fill in all those little gaps between the lack of information because I know them.
通道扩展理论背后的理念是，当你与陌生人交谈时，沟通方式比你与非常熟悉的人交谈或谈论你非常熟悉的话题时要重要得多。用通俗的话说，如果我收到一个完全陌生的人或一个几乎不算相识的人发来的短信或电子邮件，我很有可能会误解他们的信息，因为我不了解他们平时的沟通方式。但如果我收到伴侣或最好朋友发来的短信或电子邮件，我完全知道他们在说什么。我知道如何填补缺乏信息之间的所有小空白，因为我了解他们。
There's no misinterpretation. And the same effect happens with video. If versus no video on. It's better to have those extra cues in new relationships. It's better to show your new boss or a new client, hey, I'm engaged, I'm really excited. You could see me looking here at what appears to be you on the camera. And that's really important. But if it's someone you've been working with a really long time and they know your level
不会有任何误解。视频也是如此。有视频和没有视频的区别在于，在新的关系中拥有这些额外的线索会更好。向新老板或新客户展示“嘿，我很投入，我真的很兴奋”会更好。你可以看到我在这里看着摄像机里看起来像你的画面。这真的很重要。但如果对方是你共事了很长时间的人，他们知道你的投入程度，
of engagement, they know you, they trust you already, then cameras are less important in those situations. Does background matter? Does using your real background or a blur or a blur or a few? fake screen communicate different things to the person you're talking to. There's two perspectives when it comes to backgrounds in terms of the research that's been at. So this is still a pretty new area. But one perspective looks at professionalism. And it finds that backgrounds with books or plants tend to be seen as the most professional.
他们了解你，已经信任你，那么在这些情况下，摄像头的次要性就会降低。背景重要吗？使用真实背景、模糊背景还是某些虚拟屏幕，会向你交谈的人传达不同的信息吗？从研究角度来看，关于背景有两种观点。所以这仍然是一个相当新的领域。但有一种观点着眼于专业性。研究发现，摆有书本或植物的背景往往被视为最专业的。
The ones that are blurred somewhere in the middle. And the novelty backgrounds and the example in this study was a walrists sitting. on an iceberg, the least professional. The other perspective is about building relationships. And what those studies found is that when you have something in your background, like a number one dad mug, if someone else is a parent, they'll feel like they can relate to you more and trust you more because they understand you and you've got some connection.
那些模糊的背景则居于中间。而新奇的背景——这项研究中的例子是一头海象坐在冰山上——则是最不专业的。另一种观点是关于建立关系的。这些研究发现，当你的背景中有什么东西时，比如一个“头号老爸”马克杯，如果另一个人也是父母，他们会觉得更能与你共鸣，也更信任你，因为他们理解你，而且你们之间有一些共同的联系。
We like people who are similar to ourselves. And so having those cues into who you are as a human being while still remaining professional can be useful if you're looking to build trust. I have pictures of my dogs in the background as a potential conversation starter sometimes, but overall it's still professional with books and some shelves. So the idea is I try and do a little bit of mix of the professional aspect, but giving some windows into who I am as a human to remind the other person that, hey, it's a human being on the other side. You're not just interacting with your computer screen. But those goofy backgrounds are not a good idea.
我们喜欢与自己相似的人。因此，如果你想建立信任，在保持专业的同时，提供这些关于你作为一个真实的人是谁的线索会很有用。有时我的背景里有我狗狗的照片作为潜在的破冰话题，但总体而言它依然保持专业，有着书本和一些书架。所以我的想法是，我试图将专业性结合一点点，但同时敞开几扇通往我真实自我是谁的窗户，以此提醒对方：嘿，对面是一个活生生的人。你不仅仅是在与你的电脑屏幕互动。但那些滑稽搞笑的背景可不是个好主意。
In work situations, no. In social situations, obviously the story changes a bit because professionalism just doesn't matter as much. Let's switch gears and talk about email. You've looked at how people respond to typos and emails. What have you found if you accidentally send an email with a typo? How are your colleagues going to react? I did some research with Haley Blondon from American University on this topic of typos. and we had three key findings that we found in the study.
在工作场合，绝对不是。在社交场合，情况显然会发生一些变化，因为专业性没那么重要。让我们转换话题，聊聊电子邮件。你研究过人们如何回应电子邮件中的错别字。如果你不小心发送了一封带有错别字的电子邮件，你有什么发现？你的同事会有什么反应？我和美国大学（American University）的海莉·布隆登（Haley Blondon）就错别字这个话题进行了一些研究，
The first one was that typos make you look less intelligent. That's kind of obvious. No one's surprised there. The second effect that we found is that typos can actually make messages seem more emotional when there's emotion present in the message. So they can make angry emails seem angrier or happy emails seem happier. And the underlying theory of this is that when people see the typos, they say, this person's so emotional, they weren't focused on writing this properly, basically.
我们在研究中发现了三个关键发现。第一个发现是，错别字会让你显得不那么聪明。这有点显而易见。没有人会对此感到惊讶。我们发现的第二个效应是，当信息中存在情绪时，错别字实际上会让信息显得更有情绪。所以它们会让生气的邮件显得更生气，或者让快乐的邮件显得更快乐。其背后的理论是，当人们看到错别字时，他们会说：这个人太情绪化了，根本没有心思把这封信写好。
And the third effect that we found is that in the presence of emotion, typos result in a lower intelligence penalty to the sender. So in other language, basically, if you have a typo in a neutral message, it's going to make you look less intelligent than if you have a typo in an emotional message because people say, oh, it's the emotion that's the cause of the typo as opposed to the person's lack of intelligence. And this relates to a whole lot of other studies on typos as well. So research shows that when you have sent from my iPhone at the bottom of your email and your signature, typos also are penalized less in terms of perceptions of the sender because people are thinking, oh, it's because they're sent from their iPhone. And then there's another set of studies
我们发现的第三个效应是，在存在情绪的情况下，错别字给发件人带来的智力惩罚较小。换句话说，基本上，如果你在一条中性信息中出现错别字，会比你在一条充满情绪的信息中出现错别字显得更不聪明，因为人们会说：哦，是情绪导致了错别字，而不是这个人缺乏智力。这与许多关于错别字的其它研究也有关。因此，研究表明，当你的电子邮件底部签名有“发自我的 iPhone”时，由于人们会想“哦，这是因为它是从 iPhone 发出的”，因此在对发件人的感知方面，错别字的惩罚也较轻。然后还有另一组研究
that shows that when people realize the email senders from a different culture, or typos are penalized less or grammar errors are penalized less because people are thinking, oh, it's because English may not be their first language. And the core takeaway of all this is that in virtual communication,
表明，当人们意识到电子邮件发件人来自不同的文化背景时，错别字受到的惩罚就会减少，或者语法错误受到的惩罚就会减少，因为人们会想：哦，这是因为英语可能不是他们的母语。这一切的核心结论是，在虚拟沟通中，
there's often a lot of ambiguity. So people are searching for reasons for your behavior. And when it's typos are saying, well, is it intelligence or is it emotion or is it the mobile device they use? or their culture. And if you have these potential issues, making sure you provide the reasoning
往往存在很多歧义。因此，人们总是在为你的行为寻找原因。当出现错别字时，他们会想：这是智力问题，还是情绪问题，还是他们使用的移动设备的问题，或者是他们的文化问题？如果你存在这些潜在问题，确保提供理由可以真正帮助你确保不会因这些问题而受到惩罚。例如，如果你给同事发了一封带有错别字的电子邮件，后来你意识到了，并且担心这会让你看起来很糟糕，你可以快速发送一条跟进信息，说：嘿，我刚回到办公桌前，
can really help to make sure that you're not penalized for those issues. So for instance, if you send an email with typos to a colleague and you realize it, and you're concerned it's going to make you look really bad, you could do a quick follow-up saying, hey, I just got to my desk,
我发现我上一条信息里有一堆错别字。我当时在路上，想尽快让你知道这件事，因为我意识到这很重要。这样一来，你就在给他们一个理由。这是因为你想尽快让他们知道某事以对他们有益。这并不是因为你懒惰、不在乎、
I saw there were a bunch of typos in my last message. I was on the go and I wanted to let you know this as soon as possible, because I realized it was important. So then you're giving them the reason. It's because you wanted to let them know something as soon as possible for their benefit. It's not about you being lazy or not caring
或者不聪明。所以你要确保在那些虚拟互动中填补这些空白。这就是发挥主动性的时候。表情符号或诸如 LOL、FW 或 IRL 之类的缩写的运用呢？我经常遇到的最常见问题之一可能就是关于表情符号的。
or not intelligent. So you want to make sure to fill in those gaps and those virtual interactions. That's about taking that initiative there. What about the use of emojis or abbreviations like L-O-L or F-W or I-R-L? One of the most common questions I probably get is about emojis.
这不仅来自大学本科生，一直到 C 级高管。我应该把那个笑脸放进去吗？那会对我有帮助吗？我应该使用感叹号吗？在这种情况下我该怎么做？关于这方面的研究相当参差不齐。这样做有一些好处。
And it's both from like undergraduate students all the way up to C-suite executives. Should I put that smiley face in there? Will that help me? Should I use exclamation marks? What should I do in those situations? And the research on this is fairly mixed. There are some benefits.
在某些情况下，它可能会让你显得更有能力。在其他情况下，它可能会让你显得更热情，或者可能会让你显得没那么有能力。这真的取决于具体情况。但所有这些研究的核心启示是，最佳策略被称为“语言趋同”（language mimicry）。这个想法是，你从对方那里获取线索。如果他们使用表情符号，你也应该使用。
In certain cases, it may make you look more competent. In other cases, it may make you look warmer or it may make you look less competent. It really depends. but what a key takeaway from all this research is is that the best strategy is something called language mimicry. So this is the idea that you take your cues from the other person. If they use emojis, you should use them too.
如果他们使用大量感叹号，考虑也这么做。如果他们使用像 LOL 这样的缩写，那么考虑做类似的事情。这种方法之所以如此有效，原因在于：第一，我们信任那些与我们更相似的人，因为我们觉得我们懂他们。因此，当某人的沟通方式像我们时，我们会信任他们。第二，我们都认为自己是伟大的沟通者。因此，当其他人像我们一样沟通时，我们会想：哇，他们也是个很棒的沟通者。这里需要注意的一点是，你不想矫枉过正，把他们所做的一切都复制下来，弄得几乎像是在玩“西蒙说”（Simon says）的游戏，因为事实证明那样会适得其反。所以你不能在这方面做得太疯狂。但是
If they use lots of exclamation marks, consider doing the same. If they use abbreviations like LOL, then consider doing something similar. And the reason this works so well is that, one, we trust people, who are more similar to us because we feel like we get them. So when someone communicates like us, we trust them. And two, we all think we're great communicators. So when someone else communicates like us, we think, wow, they're a great communicator too. The one note with this is you don't want to go way overboard where you're copying everything they do and it becomes a game that Simon says almost because that has been shown to backfire. So you don't want to go crazy with it. But
这里的教训同样不是去盲目决定“这就是绝对最佳的方法”。而是要观察语境，看看对方做了什么，然后模仿那种行为。我们在 APA（美国心理学协会）有一个老笑话。作为一个当了很长时间的记者和编辑的人，我并不是感叹号的粉丝。我告诉别人，只有当句子是“救命”或“着火了”时，你才使用感叹号。所以这个笑话是，每个人都给我发数百万个感叹号，
The lesson here is, again, not just deciding, okay, this is the absolute best approach. It's looking at the context, seeing what the other person does, and then mirroring that kind of behavior. We have kind of a standing joke at APA. I am not a fan of exclamation points, having been a reporter and editor for a long time. And I tell people, you only use an exclamation point if the sentence is help or fire. And so the joke is, everybody sends me a million exclamation points. and, you know, they're yanking my chain.
你知道的，他们是在开我的玩笑。所以我想，如果你对电子邮件的外观有点死板，你就会经常遇到这种情况。将一些乐趣带回虚拟互动中对于帮助建立这种凝聚力、稍微活跃一下气氛会非常有用。所以，当然，当我稍后给你发感谢邮件时，我得决定：我是该加上 50 个感叹号，还是忍住别加？好吧，请问，作为一个远程办公人员（我就是），保持老板和同事随时了解你的工作进展的正确方式是什么？当他们每天都看不到你时，你该如何让他们知道你的生产力有多高？你是否会因为过度沟通而适得其反？
So I guess you get a little bit of that if you're a little hidebound about how your email should look. Bringing back some fun into virtual interactions can be really useful for helping to build that bonding, for helping to lighten the mood a little bit. So, of course, when I send you a thank you email later, I'll have to decide, do I throw in 50 exclamation marks or do I hold off there? Well, let me ask, as a remote worker, which I am, what's the right way to keep bosses and coworkers updated on your work? How can you let them know how productive you're being when they can't see you every day? And can you make that backfire by over communicating?
这是我看到远程工作和管理者评估工作时遇到的最大问题之一。心理学中有一个非常有趣的效应叫做“投入偏误”（input bias），也就是说，我们倾向于根据某人似乎投入了多少努力来衡量某件事有多好。在研究人员针对该主题进行的最初一组研究中，他们让管理者评估一个演示文稿或一组演示文稿。在一种情况下，他们被告知做演示的人花在创建演示文稿上的时间超过了八个小时。在另一种情况下，他们被告知参与者花了 20 或 30 分钟进行准备。
This is one of the biggest issues that I see with remote work and managers evaluating the work. There's a really interesting effect in psychology called the input bias, which is that we tend to gauge how good something is based on how much effort it seems someone puts into it. So in the initial set of research studies that researchers had conducted on the topic, they had managers evaluate a presentation or a set of presentations. In one condition, they were told the person who did the presentation spent over eight hours creating the presentation. In the other condition, they were told the participants spent 20 or 30 minutes preparing.
如果你去想管理者会给哪一个评价更高，他们最终对八小时演示文稿的评价要高于 20 或 30 分钟的那一个。但关键在于，参与者在不同的条件下看到的其实是相同的演示文稿。唯一改变的是被告知某人花在这上面的时间。这里出现的问题是：你想要哪种员工？是花八小时完成同一任务的人，还是花 30 分钟的人？你当然想要花 30 分钟的那个人，但受到奖励的却不是他。如果我是为管理者和纯粹的领导者写一本书，我就会讨论如何改进评估。但这是一本写给所有人的书。
And if you think about which one managers were rated better, they ended up rating the eight-hour presentation better than the one that was 20 or 30 minutes. But here's the thing, participants saw the same presentations across conditions. The only thing that was changed was the amount of time they were told the person was doing it. The problem that comes in here is which employee would you want? The one who takes eight hours to do the same task or the one that takes 30 minutes. Of course you want the one that takes 30 minutes, but that's not the one who's being rewarded. If I'd written a book for managers and purely leaders, I'd be talking about how to fix evaluations. But this is a book for everyone.
所以我讨论的是你在这种情况下如何工作。如果你是远程工作者，你如何确保你的付出被看到？最简单的方法之一就是确保你以合理的频率进行沟通。如果我们比较两名员工，一个在周五给经理发了一封包含五个段落的电子邮件，汇报他们本周所做的工作，而另一个
So I talk about how do you work in those situations? If you're a remote worker, how do you make sure that your effort is seen? And one of the easiest ways to do this is to make sure that you communicate with a reasonable degree of frequency. If we were comparing two employees, one who emails our manager on Friday, a five-paragraph update about what they did for the week, and then another. one who emails their manager or sends a quick instant message each day with just a few short sentences about what happened that day. The thing about these two employees is they sent the exact
员工每天给经理发一封电子邮件或发一条简短的即时消息，只有几句短句，说明那天发生了什么。这两名员工的共同点在于，他们发送的沟通量完全相同。一个人在周五写了五个段落，另一个人把它分散在了一周当中。但那个把沟通分散在一周当中的员工会显得更有存在感，好像他们每天都在做点什么。因此，以合理但更高的频率进行互动会非常有用。然后你问了关于“是否会过度沟通”的问题。所以，当谈到过度沟通与沟通不足时，研究表明，最好显然是获得理想数量的沟通。但问题是，在任何特定情况下很难判断理想数量是多少。所以问题就变成了：我是否会过度沟通？
same amount of communication. One did five paragraphs on Friday, one spread it throughout the week. But that one that spread it throughout the week is going to seem more present, like they were doing something each day. So interacting with a reasonable but higher degree of frequency can be really useful. And then you ask this question about can you over communicate. So when it comes to over versus under communication, the research shows that it's best to obviously get the ideal amount of communication. But the problem is, it's hard to tell in any given situation what the ideal amount is. So then the question becomes, do I over communicate?
同样的沟通总量。一个人在周五写了五个段落，另一个人把它分散在一周内完成。但那个分散在一周内的人会显得更有存在感，好像他们每天都在做事。因此，以合理但更高的频率进行互动会非常有用。然后你问了这样一个问题：是否会过度沟通。所以，当谈到过度沟通与沟通不足时，研究表明，显然最好能达到理想的沟通量。但问题是，在任何特定情况下，很难判断什么是理想的沟通量。于是问题就变成了，我是不是沟通过度了？
Do I undercommunicate? What side should I err on? And it's been shown that under communication is penalized a lot more than overcommunication. If you or someone who's been on any dates recently and you send a text message, and maybe there's not a question, but the other person doesn't respond. You're wondering, did they read it? Do they not like me? Do they not care? And it's the same thing with managers, let's just say, or bosses, we send them an update.
我沟通不足吗？我该倾向于哪一方？研究表明，沟通不足受到的惩罚远比沟通过度严重得多。如果你或最近约会过的人发了一条短信，也许里面没有问题，但对方没有回复。你会想，他们看了吗？他们不喜欢我吗？他们不在乎吗？管理者或老板也是如此，假设我们给他们发了更新。
And there's no question in there, but they never respond. That they received it. They never sent a thank you. As an employee, you're kind of anxious. Do they not, do they hate it? Or did they not even look at it? Do they not care about my work? So just sending a quick response, like thank you, received, or I got it, I'll get back to in a few days, can be incredibly helpful because it removes that ambiguity.
里面没有问题，但他们从不回复。他们没有回复说收到了。他们从不道谢。作为员工，你有点焦虑。他们是不是讨厌它？还是根本没看？他们不在乎我的工作吗？所以，只需快速回复一句，比如谢谢，已收到，或者我收到了，过几天回复你，就会非常有帮助，因为它消除了这种含糊不清。
But you don't want to go to the extremes. The closer you are to the ideal amount of communication, the better. But if you're going to err on one side or the other, overcommunication is better because it shows your present. It shows you're engaged. What about using the function that enables you to see whether someone has opened your email? I mean, I personally hate that, but I don't know, am I in the minority here? Red receipts basically signal to the other person you don't trust them. And this matches the study is on the topic. So I generally do not recommend them unless it's a situation where it's completely normal to do so or the other person would very much expect that you sent a red receipt.
但你也不想走极端。你越接近理想的沟通量，效果就越好。但如果你必须偏向其中一边，沟通过度会更好，因为它表明你在线。它表明你参与其中。那么，使用能让你查看别人是否打开了你的邮件的功能呢？我的意思是，我个人讨厌这个，但我不知道，我是少数派吗？已读回执基本上向对方发出信号，表明你不信任他们。这与该主题的研究相吻合。所以我通常不推荐它们，除非在完全正常的情况下，或者对方非常期望你发送已读回执。
There aren't too many situations that fall into that kind of scenario. Two lawyers and opposite sides of court case, that may be something you would do to show the other person got it. But generally, I recommend avoiding them. Instead, if it's a situation where you can indicate to other person saying something like, hey, it'd be great if you could get me a response within X days, can be useful because then it creates a situation where it's clear when you expect a response from them. And as an added benefit, that extra line in there about when you expect a response has been
符合这种场景的情况并不多。两个在法庭上针锋相对的律师，这可能是你会做的事情，以向对方表明收到了。但总的来说，我建议避免使用它们。相反，如果可以向对方暗示一些事情，比如，嘿，如果你能在X天内给我回复那就太好了，这会很有用，因为它创造了一种情况，即你期望他们回复的时间很明确。作为一个额外的好处，关于你期望什么时候得到回复的那句额外的话已经
shown to decrease stress for the email recipient. One of the problems with the email is that we get it, and there's something called the email urgency bias, which is let's just say you send me an email. As a recipient, I'm thinking, oh, here's this really important person, you know, big podcast. They probably want a response really quickly. But on your end, you're like, I'm a busy person.
被证明可以减轻邮件接收者的压力。邮件的问题之一是我们收到了邮件，并且存在一种叫做邮件紧迫感偏见的现象，打个比方，你给我发了一封邮件。作为收件人，我在想，哦，这是一个非常重要的人物，你知道，大播客。他们可能希望很快得到回复。但在你看来，你会觉得，我是个大忙人。
I don't care if they get back to me for another three days. And this effect is true, especially for after hours communication, where it turns out that people who receive messages think the recipient wants a response a lot quicker than they do. So when you explicitly say, hey, it's fine if you get back to me tomorrow or three days, it removes that stress of needing to respond right then, right there, drop whatever you're doing. So it has that nice benefit there. And again, removing this ambiguity, taking the initiative to provide that extra information can really help to improve not just your outcomes,
我不在乎他们三天后再回复我。这种效应确实存在，尤其是对于下班后的沟通，事实证明，收到消息的人会认为接收者希望得到回复的速度比实际情况要快得多。因此，当你明确表示，嘿，如果你明天或三天后再回复我没关系，这就消除了当时必须回复、放下手头所有事情的压力。所以它有那个很好的好处。同样，消除这种模糊性，主动提供额外的信息不仅可以真正帮助改善你的结果，
but the well-being of the other person you're interacting with. One of the very newest tools in the workplace is artificial intelligence. Many workers are trying to figure out how do I incorporate AI into my work and should I be experimenting with letting AI answer my emails, for example? Is that a good idea? Should we all be considering outsourcing some of our communication to AI? Obviously, AI is a new area for research. So it's a continually developing landscape.
还能改善与你互动的另一个人的幸福感。职场中最新的工具之一就是人工智能。许多工人都试图弄清楚如何将人工智能融入到我的工作中，例如，我是否应该尝试让人工智能回答我的邮件？这是个好主意吗？我们是否都应该考虑将部分沟通外包给人工智能？显然，人工智能是一个全新的研究领域。所以这是一个不断发展的领域。
But based on the research, some of which is my own on authenticity, if you were to ask me, should I let AI do all my communication? So you get something from chat GPT or perplexity or Gemini and copy and paste into email or maybe come up with scripts for you to read during video calls to make sure what you're saying is really on point. My advice is no. My perspective is that there will always be value to a human component of communication. And my own research and authenticity shows that the greater effort someone is perceived as putting
但根据研究（其中一些关于真实性的研究是我自己的），如果你问我，我应该让人工智能处理我所有的沟通吗？也就是说你从 ChatGPT、Perplexity 或 Gemini 获取内容并复制并粘贴到电子邮件中，或者可能想出脚本供你在视频通话期间阅读，以确保你所说的话真正切中要害。我的建议是不会。我的观点是，沟通的人性化部分将永远具有价值。我关于真实性的研究表明，人们感知到某人付出的努力越多
into an interaction, the more authentic it comes off. Think about it this way. Let's just say you send someone in email that you used AI for. Most times, they're not going to realize it. But once they might, maybe the AI used a word that you don't normally. use. Or maybe you and your coworker talked about something that happened that past weekend. Maybe they talk about how their whole family had the stomach bug. And then you send them an email that says, I hope you had a great weekend, exclamation mark. And the thing is, the AI tools don't know
投入到互动中，它就显得越真实。换个角度想。假设你给某人发了一封使用过人工智能的电子邮件。大多数时候，他们不会意识到。但有时他们可能会，也许人工智能使用了你平时不用的词。或者你和你的同事谈论了上周末发生的事情。也许他们谈论他们的全家人都得了肠胃性感冒。然后你给他们发了一封电子邮件，上面写着，祝你周末愉快，感叹号。问题是，人工智能工具并不知道
everything that's in your head. So then one of these times something sneaks through. The person who gets that will realize, okay, they used AI here. But then they're going to question every single interaction they've had with you and wonder, have they always just been using AI? And then they're going to be questioning, well, why am I interacting with this person in the first place if all they're doing is giving me AI communication? And that's not to say that AI isn't useful. It's great for editing, brainstorming, helping you when you get stuck. And for low stakes repeated interactions, sure, use it. But for those important high-stakes ones, you do want to make sure that the words are yours in your communication. Last question, now that you've completed the
你脑子里的一切。所以其中有一次，有些东西漏网了。收到那个的人会意识到，好吧，他们在这里使用了人工智能。但随后他们会质疑他们与你之间的每一次互动，并想知道，他们是不是一直都在使用人工智能？然后他们会质疑，如果他们所做的只是给我提供人工智能沟通，我为什么首先要与这个人互动？这并不是说人工智能没有用。它非常适合编辑、集思广益、在遇到困难时提供帮助。对于风险较低的重复互动，当然可以使用。但对于那些重要的、高风险的互动，你确实要确保这些词是你自己沟通中的。最后一个问题，既然你已经完成了
book and you've done all the research behind it, what are the big questions that you weren't able to answer? There's a lot of different questions that are happening now. Some of the interesting ones are about new technologies that are emerging. So, for instance, augmented reality, these glasses that you can now get, where notifications can pop up right in front of you. So what does that mean? We all know we're now attached to our smartphones and a light comes on or it makes a noise and we're checking it. What happens now when we're literally seeing everything in all those notifications in real time the moment they come in? For me, seeing how all these new technologies are going to change the way we interact, our well-being, to me is one of the coolest questions out there at the moment. Dr. Brodsky, I want to thank you for joining me.
这本书，并且做了背后的所有研究，你无法回答的大问题是什么？现在有很多不同的问题。其中一些有趣的问题是关于新兴技术的。例如，增强现实，这些你现在可以买到的眼镜，通知可以直接弹到你面前。这意味着什么？我们都知道我们现在离不开智能手机，灯亮了或者发出声音了，我们就会去查看。当我们实时看到所有这些通知，就在它们弹出的那一刻，会发生什么？对我们来说，了解所有这些新技术将如何改变我们的互动方式和幸福感，对我来说是目前最酷的问题之一。布罗茨基博士，我想感谢你加入我。
This has been very interesting and you've given me something to think about regarding how I communicate. Thank you. It's been a great conversation. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please follow us and leave a review. For those of you who want to know more about psychology and the work of APA, you can join us as a supporter. You don't have to be a psychologist. The benefits include a subscription to our award-winning magazine, Monitor on Psychology, as well as
这非常有趣，你给了我一些关于如何沟通的思考。谢谢。这是一次很棒的对话。你可以在我们的网站 speakingof psychology.org 或在 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 或你获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学之声》以前的节目。如果你喜欢你所听到的，请关注我们并留下评论。对于那些想要了解更多关于心理学和美国心理协会工作的人，你可以作为支持者加入我们。你不必是一名心理学家。福利包括订阅我们屡获殊荣的杂志《心理学监察》，以及
discounts on our books and other publications. So if psychology is your passion, or if you just want to know more about the science, you can become a supporter by visiting at.a.a.org slash speaking. That's att.a.a.org slash speaking. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Winerman. Thanks for listening for the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. Enjoy more ways to save at Ralph's, like low prices in every aisle. And when you download the Ralph's app, you can clip and save more with digital coupons every week.
我们的书籍和其他出版物的折扣。因此，如果心理学是你的热情所在，或者如果你只是想了解更多关于科学的知识，你可以通过访问 at.a.a.org slash speaking 来成为支持者。那是 att.a.a.org slash speaking。如果你对未来的播客有评论或想法，你可以发送电子邮件至 speaking of psychology at APA.org。心理学之声由莉·威纳曼制作。感谢收听美国心理学协会的节目。我是金·米尔斯。在拉尔夫斯超市享受更多省钱方式，比如每个过道都有低价。当你下载拉尔夫斯应用程序时，你每周都可以通过数字优惠券剪辑并节省更多。
Plus, you can earn fuel points to save up to $1 per gallon at the pump. At Ralph's, you can enjoy more ways to save and more rewards every time you shop. So it's always easy to save big every day with savings and rewards. Ralph's SoCal for over 150 years, savings may vary by state. Fuel restrictions apply. C-Sight for details. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
此外，您还可以赚取燃料积分，在加油站每加仑节省高达 1 美元的费用。在拉尔夫斯，您每次购物都可以享受更多省钱方式和更多奖励。因此，通过节省和奖励，每天都可以轻松省下大钱。拉尔夫斯南加州超过 150 年，省钱金额可能因州而异。燃料限制适用。详见网站。本集尚无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可留下评论。